Speaker 1: A few days ago, David did a story
about a man who went to an Arlington City
Council meeting and said the punishment for being
gay. Is death or it should be death. That man
came from the same church as a pastor that we're
going to look at today in a disturbing clip that
has gone viral. Steadfast Church is the name of
the church. And he said just like his, I guess,
colleague or someone else who went to that
same church, that gay people should be killed.
But this one went as far as to specifically say
how they should be shot in the back of the head.
Warning. This is very disturbing.
But let's take a look.
Speaker 7: I'd say is the answer is
the solution for the homosexual in 2022
here in the New Testament, here in the book
of Romans, that they are worthy of death.
These people should be put to death. Every single
homosexual in our country should be charged with a
crime. The abomination of homosexuality that they
have. They should be convicted in a lawful trial.
They should be sentenced with death. They should
be lined up against the wall and shot in the
back of the head. That's what God teaches. That's
what the Bible says. You don't like it. You don't
like God's word because that is what God said.
Speaker 1: I mean, what is there to say to that?
It's disturbing. It's disgusting, all the things.
But the fact that he's pretending to be expressing
these views because he feels it is the word of
God is horrible. I mean, you are hateful. Deeply,
deeply hateful. You don't feel called by God to
say and do these things. You have a deep hatred
in your heart. And are desperate to find an excuse
to spew it everywhere that you can in the world.
And let's address what he's saying. Seriously,
I don't know why we would do that, but let's
do it anyways. If you don't understand that your
specific religions sets of beliefs can be enforced
on everyone in a country. You don't understand
our Constitution. You don't understand how a
functioning society would work. Free democratic
society. So even if he genuinely believe this
was his religion, this is what God was
calling him to do. There is absolutely no way.
You could figure out a way to justify enforcing
your specific beliefs on an entire country of
people and wanting to them who scull a lot
of rage and almost like a heart palpitation.
What the heck? And kill people because of
your religion or your interpretation of your
religion. And let me make something clear. There
are wonderful Christians. There are beautiful so
many Christians. I'm Christian raised and tons
of people around me are amazing Christians. They
serve the country. They serve the people around
them. They see Jesus's teachings as being
service oriented, helping people
who are disadvantaged, advantaged,
loving people unconditionally, all those things.
And they're amazing. This is not all Christians.
And like I said before, I don't even think
this is Christianity. I think this man is using
Christianity to express views he already has deep
down in his heart because he is a hateful person.
For some reason, the concept of anyone being
different, anyone loving different scares him.
Probably born out of deep, deep insecurity. But
then he uses. A religious text to justify spewing
his hatred. And I'm noticing as broader society
move forward, like over the last few generations,
we move forward a lot on LGBTQ issues. A
small portion is kind of reacting to that
progress by launching way backwards. And we can't
allow this as a country. We can't allow. A small
minority of this country to inflict pain on other
groups of people just because of their weird,
distorted, perverted understanding of
their own religion. That's not acceptable.
And I think every religious person or
non-religious person should be able to unite
around the fact, regardless of our disagreements
otherwise. But this should not be allowed and
this should not be accepted in our country. He's
calling for the murder of people just because they
live differently than him and don't subscribe to
his particular set of religious religious beliefs.
As I said, I was raised Christian. I know tons of
Christians in my life and I know all of them would
be just as disgusted as I am by watching this.
And so how about you go out? If you're someone
like him and you believe what he believes, how
will you actually do something in the world this
good? I see this. And I had someone point out to
me and I'm never one to forget to point this out.
Tons of people who are religious. Do
amazing things with it. That's what I
do with my religion. I do good things with
it. It motivates people to do good things.
And tons of the charity and service that we
see in our country is done by people who are
motivated by their religious beliefs. So this
isn't a massive thing on religion. This is.
People who only want to use a religion
to feel better than other people.
And that's him. And I just wish I could look at
him in the face and say, How will you do something
good for the world? Right now you're sitting
here festering in your hate for other people.
And you're trying to get your audience and your
followers and supporters to believe the same thing
and you're threatening people's lives. What good
is that doing for the world? What good is that
doing for you, for God that you believe in? What
good is that doing in living a life of Jesus?
It's not. Everyone understands if they read
enough of the Bible while there's a lot of
stuff in there like, Whoa, what's going on? I
can't wait. At least if you zero in on the Jesus
stories, he was a very, very giving
and loving and serving person.
So how will you go out and you give and you love
and you serve you disgusting human, human being.
But no, you just want to stand there.
You want to get the attention of people
and you want to talk about how much you hate
people for being different than you. It's so. I'm
so sick of having to listen to this. And he should
be arrested. Right. That's a criminal level of. A
threatening of violence. A judge did rule
likely that a steadfast church will be evicted,
going to be evicted for allowing
threats of violence. So hurray on that.
But super scary and harmful stuff. You can
hear further discussions about this topic
in general. I'm always getting fired up about
people going after already marginalized groups
for absolutely no reason on my channel. If
you want to watch that, you can go to Luke
Beasley on YouTube or if you're watching
this on YouTube, listening to the podcast,
there will be a link in the description you can
click to check me out. Be greatly appreciated.